despite countless empty shelves record
high inflation and mass shipping
backlogs the white house bragging how it
saved christmas for americans
good news we've saved christmas the
stocks on shelves is at about 90 percent
retail stocks on shelves at about 90
inventory it's about nine it was about
91 percent pre pandemic just to give you
a sense so
people can go purchase uh purchase
presents even even at this point if they
haven't done their shopping
and president biden going one step
further claiming the supply chain crisis
never really existed
the much predicted crisis didn't occur
packages are moving
gifts are being delivered
shelves are not empty
all right we're blessed on this show
because we have the original foot
soldier on the war on christmas he also
saved the world so jesse waters did joe
biden actually save christmas i did he
plagiarized my book chapter nine
how i saved the world still available
that will get there in time if you order
it right now i don't want to throw too
much mud if people are getting gifts
under the tree in time that's a good
thing uh if biden deserves credit i'll
give him credit i don't know if he does
deserve credit cause what did he do he
told the ports to stay open 24 7. they
didn't um but according to reports
things are a lot better than they were
in november i think people just shopped
smarter and the ports threatened to find
a bunch of these cargo ships there's
still a ton of ships idling offshore
we're still going to have supply chain
problems shortages empty shelves in
2022. so
if i were joe biden that's what i would
say everything should be made in america
i don't want to pick up something and
see that it's made in china so we're
going to bring the jobs back the
factories back bring them back to
america or at least
north or south america just get it
closer so the ships don't have to come
all the way across the pacific from a
communist country with a history of
slave labor and viruses
so what you're saying is channel donald
trump let's go america first again right
made in america right
in america but that but you make up you
make a good point because as he said i
saved christmas i scratch my head and go
well richard what actually did he do to
save christmas what policies did he
implement to save christmas to make the
supply chain work better
well look i i'll say this i agreed with
jesse a little bit at the beginning so i
appreciate your honesty jesse but with
that being said look i i i i hear what i
hear folks is frustration but remember
in august and september the conversation
that we were having on the five on other
shows across this channel and all across
the news media was will the christmas
shelves be empty will you be able to get
your child the newest gi joe toy or will
you be able to get your child to
playstation 4. the truth of the matter
is is you can get your child all those
things right and so the fact that that's
the truth means that the president and
his team did the work they said they
were going to do is there more work to
be done absolutely we are living in a
current inflationary market which is why
what i want to see in the new year is
this president focused on how he helps
working families bring down the cost of
child care how does he help senior
citizens by bringing down the cost of
prescription drugs and how does he helps
so many families out there looking for
housing because the cost of the rent is
too high
well but but richard i think you make a
good point which is it works now but the
question was did joe biden do anything
to make it work it's probably the
private sector that actually stepped up
and tried to figure out how we get rid
of the kids well i do think i i mean i
do think the fact that this president at
the time we had there's still ships at
the ports waiting to unload but with
that being said this president and his
team made sure that the ports stayed
open they worked with ups and fedex and
corporate leaders to ensure that the
packages were getting to people and
folks are getting the research
there are no specific policies that the
the administration implemented but to
you katie i mean is there more supply
out there because of inflation and
rising prices that people just had to
buy less because i've talked to a lot of
you know you know working-class people
who go listen i just i didn't have the
money to buy what i normally would buy i
had to buy less so does that mean
there's more things on the shelf
well first of all i would say it's
always interesting when politicians want
went credit for doing their job i mean
the first the administration claimed
that there wasn't a supply chain crisis
and now they're claiming victory for
eliminating the supply chain crisis and
okay sure the the stores may be more
stocked than they were a month ago but
families can't afford it their natural
gas bills are up by 40 thanks to this
administration their gas that they fill
up their car to go christmas shopping
cost twice as much as it did a year ago
all of their
savings are getting wiped out by
inflation if you look at their paychecks
if they've gotten a raise all of that
has been wiped out by inflation and if
you look at wholesale prices they just
keep going up so
sure there's stuff on the shelves but
families can't afford to buy as much as
they used to all right kaylee final
thoughts to you white house taking
credit for something they probably
created themselves with paying people to
stay at home and you know having school
shut down so one parent has to stay in
zoom with their kids
yeah
i saved christmas wow that is not an
effective talking point because the
american people don't agree i mean what
the white house is saying is look over
here ignore everything over there ignore
the testing crisis ignore the fact that
joe biden has the worst economic
approval rating since jimmy carter
negative 13 is where it stands uh the
average president in the last 44 years
has been plus five so he's literally 18
points below on the economy of an
average president in the last four
decades so go ahead say you saved
christmas it's not going to help you
save the house in the midterms yeah but
you're not allowed to celebrate
christmas that he saved unless everybody
including the dog and cat is boosted
100 by the way get it right joe you did
not you did not save christmas jesse
waters saved christmas thank you and a
story all right
and the world too that's right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else